[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola como estan mi nombre es carlos
minis cuando tenía alrededor de 6 años
mi papá me hizo una pregunta una
pregunta muy simple me dijo carla
como te ves en la vida que quieres hacer
más adelante cuando terminas el colegio
y para mí fue una pregunta muy sencilla
y yo le dije obviamente quiero ser una
persona exitosa tener mucho dinero y
alcanzar mis sueños así en esa época y
paso me miró no me dijo nada se quedó
callado pero vi cierta desilusión en su
cara yo no sabía por qué
y había sido muy buena alumna en el
colegio
y para mí no sería difícil entrar a la
universidad de hecho ahí me ven en
último día de colegio en mi graduación
había estudiado o quería estudiar
economía y así lo hice escogí esa
carrera para supuestamente seguir mis
sueños en búsqueda en búsqueda del
bienestar en busca de mi felicidad
así fue
pasaron los años
tuve muchísimos trabajos trabajé desde
los 18 años me gradué la carrera que yo
tenía y luego más adelante tuve la
oportunidad de tener
de viajar el extranjero pude irme a eeuu
donde pude estudiar administración pero
también tuve la oportunidad de trabajar
y hacer varias cosas que me apasionaron
pero una de las experiencias que
particularmente me llamaron la atención
fue cuando trabajé en la escuela pública
educativa del sistema público de eeuu y
yo trabajaba haciendo investigación para
detectar cuál había sido el impacto de
la educación de calidad que le otorgaba
esa escuela en los alumnos nosotros
hacíamos muchísimos ensayos
comparaciones hacíamos muchísimas
estadísticas y también ese trabajo puede
conocer a muchos estudiantes
internacionales y con ellos con el
consejo estudiantil nosotros diseñamos
maneras de como ellos podían tener la
mejor experiencia educativa con
actividades que les permitiera estar
súper enganchados con la universidad con
el college
y pensé que a mí me gustaba muchísimo
ese trabajo y esa ciudad que se llamaba
portland maine recuerdo
tuve que salir de esa ciudad para buscar
mi sueño como les decía para seguir fiel
a mi sueño que era tener dinero que era
tener éxito porque yo decía que así un
economista acá
trabajando en educación un economista
tiene que estar pues en un banco de
inversión tiene que estar ganando mucho
dinero
haciendo mucha plata y bueno y siguiendo
esa esa ley mía recordando lo que le
había hecho a mi papá me voy a boston a
trabajar en un banco de inversión de
hecho bank of america era el mejor banco
de inversión en ese momento
efectivamente ganaba tres veces más
tenía una oficina muy lujosa muy bonita
pero pasaba algo y yo llevaba los días
tarde al trabajo porque no me gustaba
ese trabajo además ha sido la tía que no
me gustaba que era cerrarle la cuenta de
los latinos que yo decía pero por qué
injusticia espero hacer la política del
banco en esa época
y recuerdo que no veía las horas para
que eso de las 5 de la tarde yo jugara
me fuera rápido entonces yo me di cuenta
que eso no era lo mío que por ahí estaba
mi felicidad que yo no me veía
trabajando ahí 20 años ni 10 años y es
así que apenas tuve yo la oportunidad me
regreso en mi país y trabajando en el
sector educativo una lo que me gustaba y
ahí en verdad yo estaba en mi salsa
trabajando en gestión educativa no es
cierto y esos trabajos me llevaron a uno
el cual recuerdo con muchísimo muchísimo
cariño y fue que me ofrecieron ser
directora ejecutiva de una ong que se
dedicaba a promover el emprendimiento en
los jóvenes y en las mujeres que se
llama hay una chica meant y a partir de
ese trabajo en verdad yo sentí que todo
hacía clic que la economía que había
estudiado junto a la administración de
la mano con todo lo que yo sabía el
contacto con los jóvenes y la comunidad
me permitían realmente estar plena y
vivir de acuerdo a mis valores y ya no
me pasaba eso que tenía que levantarme a
regañar y me levantaba feliz porque
sentía que estaba enganchando y que
estaba siendo fiel a mi felicidad
y en esa etapa de mi vida tuve la
oportunidad de se recaba muchísimos
lugares del mundo fue también algo muy
lindo también porque pudimos hacer
iniciativas que no solamente impactaron
en comunidades locales sino podemos
hacer de la mano con otras
organizaciones con nuestra educación con
otras empresas políticas educativas a
nivel nacional que nos permitió
capacitar a muchísimos jóvenes en lo que
es emprendimiento y eso en verdad me
llenaba mucho porque sentía que mi país
necesitaba trabajar muy duro con lo que
esa educación había yo descubierto una
realidad
muy complicada en el país que no lo
hubiera podido descubrir nunca estando
en eeuu y eso así también como en estos
viajes en esta en estas oportunidades
que me daba el mundo corporativo mi
carrera pude acceder a un seminario de
liderazgo en donde tuve la oportunidad
de conocer también a los mejores coaches
del mundo
y una de las cosas que yo recuerdo y que
más me marcaron en mi vida fue cuando
conocí a este coach que se llamaba
richard líder y él me dijo me preguntó a
esta pregunta trascendental que me marcó
para siempre y me hizo esta pregunta que
para mí no tal vez la primera no la
primera respuesta no fue tan difícil
pero la segunda si la pregunta era ésta
carla cuáles son los dos días más
importantes de tu vida y como les dije
la primera dije a alto que la primera el
día que nací por cierto ustedes piensan
lo mismo y efectivamente él me dijo si
el día más importante o el primer día
más importante de tu vida es el día que
tú has nacido y el segundo carla
el segundo así me la puso difícil le
dije un montón de respuestas y me decía
no desea otra no otra nada
y bueno me rendí y le dije richard cuál
es el día el segundo día más importante
de todo ser humano que para todo ser
humano debería ser el segundo día más
importante de tu vida debería ser el día
en que conociste tu propósito
este día este día debe ser el día más
importante de tu vida porque tú vas a
vivir de acuerdo a tu dirección de curet
os objetivos decora tu pasión y en ese
momento luego de que él me dijera eso mi
vida cambió y me había dado cuenta que
hasta la fecha todas las decisiones que
yo había tomado
hasta hace ese momento en mi primera
etapa en mi vida había sido basadas en
el dinero basadas en mi bienestar
basados en mí mismo había estado en un
mundo muy superficial y me di cuenta que
ahora yo era más feliz en este mundo
educativo donde yo podía hacer las cosas
que me encantará porque había estado
tomando las decisiones de acuerdo a lo
que me hacía más feliz de acuerdo a lo
que me llenaba de acuerdo a los valores
de acuerdo a lo que mis padres me habían
enseñado y de acuerdo a lo que el mundo
necesitaba
en este momento y lo mejor de todo es
que podía vivir de eso encima me pagaban
así algo que me encanta y encima me
pagaban entonces definitivamente dije
ahora entiendo todo y en adelante las
decisiones en mi vida fueron mucho más
fáciles porque todo fue en base a ese
propósito en base a esa dirección en
base a ese por qué por qué te levantas
todas las mañanas y qué te dice que
cuando yo no puedes más está muy cansado
te empuja ese es el propósito
y así fue cómo construir no mi propósito
o mi porque personal porque cada
destacar en el mundo porque yo vine acá
solamente para acumular riqueza y luego
irme si así como vengo me voy a ir sin
nada
entonces yo construye este círculo
dorado de carla que era mi por qué y mí
porque definitivamente había sido que yo
vine a este mundo para empoderar a
jóvenes para empoderar a mujeres para
empoderar a comunidades de la mano con
organizaciones para que podamos hacer un
impacto social mucho más grande a través
del emprendimiento la tecnología y el
mundo global que eran las cosas que a mí
me habían hecho ser exitosa el
emprendimiento esas habilidades de
liderazgo que yo había desarrollado yo
quería que otras personas también las
tengan y estaba convencida que si otras
personas otras mujeres otros jóvenes
inclusive tres líderes lo tenían iban a
hacer muchas cosas mejor por el perú
con la tecnología también me había dado
cuenta que sin tecnología esto no podría
ser posible y lo más importante que
tengan esa mirada global así como yo que
había podido descubrir el mundo había
podido ir más ciudades había podido
conocer gente que me permitió aprender
muchísimas cosas y yo pensé que eso
también yo quería hacerlo para que la
gente para otros jóvenes tengan éxito y
bueno ya pesar de que estaba en un mundo
tan bonito que ahora mi trabajo en
verdad que me levantaba muy motivada
tenía un equipo tan lindo tenía que ese
trabajo y yo me pregunto no porque
tendría que dejar un trabajo tan bonito
tan bien remunerado lo que me hace
sentir también cómodo con sueldo pasado
porque dejaría este mundo corporativo
para hacer lo que les voy a decir bueno
tuve que dejar ese trabajo tomé la
decisión y me fue muy fácil tomar la
decisión por un motivo primero bueno yo
tenía mi propósito ya sabía lo que yo
tenía que hacer en la vida mi objetivo
era empoderar jóvenes a mujeres a
comunidades para que este mundo sea un
mundo mejor a través de educación eso
era mi propósito
pero tenía este desafío y cuál era mi
desafío pues mi desafío mi desafío
personal era que mi esposo y mi hijo en
este momento tenían que eeuu y ahí me
ven yo no en mi mundo en lima los
veranos 28° feliz en la playa versus no
al mundo que me tocaba vivir o que me
tocó vivir cuando dejé ese trabajo
porque tenía que mudarme una ciudad que
es portland me una ciudad muy fría donde
pasar de 28 grados centígrados pasamos
al menos 28 grados centígrados
entonces pero aún así yo seguía adelante
porque conocía mi propósito y así como
fundó el cuerpo yo decía cómo puedo
hacer para partir de mi propósito seguir
haciendo lo que más me gusta lo puedo
hacer pero sí no pero lo mío era de eeuu
era pero mi público mi gente lo que a mí
me necesitaban era los peruanos como
hacer y es así como nacen wen por esta
organización sin fines de lucro con
miras justamente empoderar a las mujeres
a las comunidades organizaciones a
través de transferencia de conocimientos
transferencia educativa y así es como
nace wen pos esa fue la historia y fue
un camino difícil definitivamente es un
camino difícil pero que fue lo que me
ayudó lo que me ayudó porque ese círculo
dorado donde carla se convirtió en el
círculo dorado de wen po y es así como
nosotros hicimos consultorías
desarrollamos muchísimos
transferencia conocimiento hicimos
programas de aceleración programa de
asistencia técnica no pudimos en verdad
lograr un impacto en la sociedad en mi
comunidad
y justo en esas consultorías en las que
estábamos trabajando en cuerpo con el
equipo nos tocó conocer no en plena
pandemia recuerdo a los actores
educativos
del perú
y nos dimos cuenta que en verdad la
pandemia había causado destrozos
obviamente pero que seguro castigó
muchísimo más el 93 por ciento de los
estudiantes y padres de familias de
acuerdo a los estudios que hicimos en
cuento y otros no se encontraban
satisfechos estas han tenido muchísimos
problemas con la educación online los
alumnos están aprendiendo un porcentaje
ínfimo de lo que normalmente aprendía y
también habíamos descubierto que más del
95% de los profesores afirmaban que no
podían conectarse no solamente a partir
la tecnología sino que no podían
conectar socio emocionalmente a través
de una máquina no podían enseñar no
sabían cómo hacerlo ni con la
infraestructura así y así tuve la
infraestructura no sabían cómo hacerlo
cómo conectar a través de otra
metodología que la educación a distancia
y es así
juntamos wing vocal y un poco de mí que
es muy enfocada era una plataforma
disruptiva que justamente les enseñamos
a los profesores a tener una nueva
mirada de la educación una plataforma
disruptiva educativa con contenidos pero
sobre todo con metodologías para que
ellos aprendieran a enseñar en este
nuevo mundo virtual
el nuevo mundo de la pandemia y así con
una mirada disruptiva empezamos a
trabajar con todos los docentes con
todos esos con todas esas personas que
tenían estos grandes problemas y bueno y
verdad que trabajamos muy duro en todo
el perú trabajamos también unidos en la
pandemia como época de mi pudimos no
solamente trabajar solo sino empezamos a
articular con las empresas empezamos a
trabajar con las ugeles empezamos a
trabajar con las direcciones regionales
educativas hasta también poder articular
esas mujeres y esas tres nos ayudaron a
convocar a todos los docentes y se formó
en verdad una linda cruzada educativa y
todo poder hacerlo juntos por el perú en
una época que no nos necesita muchísimo
y bueno y pudimos certificar con esta
nueva tecnología disruptiva con todas
estas ganas de impactar y sobre todo
pensando en los estudiantes que estaban
teniendo no todos estos problemas de
aprendizaje y enseñanza pudimos
certificar a más de 900 estudiantes 200
profesores también pudimos hacer
muchísimos eventos educativos con esta
nueva mirada a enseñar pudimos también
y beneficiar a más de 2 a más de 7.000
docentes y jóvenes también muchos de
ellos y bueno y este trabajo que hicimos
fue muy lindo porque no solamente fue
reconocido por el mundo educativo sino
que también fue reconocido en poco
tiempo por el oposición emprendedor y es
así como hace poco ganamos estará chile
que es una entidad de gobierno en
chilenos nos otorgó digamos este
reconocimiento y ganamos este concurso
para la generación 2021 con miras a que
este programa un poco de mí se puede
expandir a nivel latam seguidamente
también pudimos ser reconocidos con el
desafío kunan y pudimos alcanzar las dos
finales como dos semifinalistas dentro
de 200 empresas que bien aplicado para
para un concurso en educación y bueno y
hace poco también estamos muy contentos
de haber podido organizar el primer
congreso de educación disruptiva un
congreso diferente no solamente por la
tecnología pusimos plataformas para que
los docentes pudieran también
experimentar este nuevo mundo sino
era diferente porque enseñamos esta
nueva mirada y les enseñamos a los
docentes también a reflexionar que la
educación tiene que ser diversa que hay
diferentes formas de enseñar que no
todos podemos poner a todos los chicos
digamos en un embudo y sacar digamos
personajes en serie sino todo lo
contrario de que tenemos que hacer mucho
más diversos con multi múltiples
inteligencias y también el otro que
pudimos rescatar no de este evento fue
que todos los chicos no y todos los
docentes que participaron podían tener
otra mirada y otra manera más disruptiva
de hacer las cosas
definitivamente en mi vida no ha sido
todo color de rosas de hecho todo lo que
les contaba en 2017 hasta hace cuatro
meses
he pasado en medio una tragedia familiar
si durante 2017 hasta hasta unos cuatro
meses
y mi padre mi madre batallaron contra el
cáncer no lo tuvo fácil y me preguntaba
cómo es que podría hacer todas esas
cosas yo soy hija única de hecho con una
conexión muy fuerte con mis padres y así
es como hemos podido como poder hacer
todo esto como hemos podido seguir
adelante y como definitivamente me he
caído muchas veces emocionalmente arreg
estos problemas yo decía cómo es que
podría hacer todo esto y la respuesta
sencilla no que es uno de los
superpoderes que yo recomiendo a todas
las personas que quieren como yo sé
disruptivas y cambiar y transformar y
decir por sus sueños con su propósito es
que forme un excelente equipo un equipo
que me sostuvo todo este momento un
equipo que hacía maravillas que nos
permitió crecer 300 por ciento y se
reconocía como una de las extras más
prominentes de américa latina y es por
eso que nosotros buenos salimos adelante
no tenemos un equipo peculiar es un
equipo único y de alto rendimiento
porque nosotros mezclamos dos cosas las
habilidades técnicas que son muy
importantes
combinadas con las habilidades blandas
también es muy importante pero lo más
importante este equipo es que este
equipo tiene algo que tengo yo que es
esta pasión y esta vocación y estamos
convencidos que tenemos que transformar
la educación del perú urgentemente el
segundo superpoder
que hemos desarrollado que desarrollado
para lograr todo esto es la colaboración
la disrupción la disrupción implica
mucha innovación y la innovación implica
mucha creatividad y la creatividad no es
un trabajo de un solo cerebro sino que
implica trabajar conversar ser diversos
en el equipo en mi equipo trabajamos
desde con gente que vive en san martín
con gente que está en huánuco con gente
que está en boston con gente que está en
lima y todos pensamos diferente todos
venimos educaciones públicas-privadas y
somos un sancochado como diríamos somos
diversos pero hace que nuestros
proyectos sean mucho más poderosos y
tenemos soluciones mucho más disruptivas
porque somos diferentes y colaboramos el
tercer superpoder no pasamos obviamente
mil cosas así como yo tengo problemas mi
equipo cada uno tiene problemas pero
hemos pasado por muchísimos problemas
como pasar todo el material y todo el
contenido 100% presencial a 100% online
hacer consultorías o proyectos de zonas
rurales con dificultades y cosas con
muchos desafíos
todo eso lo hacemos por la resiliencia
que es un músculo blando la resiliencia
no es una cantidad fija
lo que se estira es algo con lo que tú
nace si puedes ir desarrollando y ti no
tiene límites así que si quieres ser
disruptivo desarrolla tu residencia te
va a sacar mil veces y lo único que te a
levantar es ese valor y finalmente una
de las más importantes es la empatía
creo que nosotros hemos logrado todo
esto porque al margen de que era tener
un modelo negocio hacer mucha plata creo
que nuestro interés de la empatía era
ponernos en los zapatos de los docentes
de las personas conocer sus desafíos sus
problemas y poderles ofrecer realmente
una solución que le genere valor
y lo que único que hicimos fue conectar
con ellos de corazón a corazón así que
ya poder terminando no cuando ustedes
piensan en su futuro en su vida elijan
un trabajo que realmente les apasione y
les aseguro que van a trabajar 0 días a
la semana como nuestro equipo y
finalmente así cuando tengas tu trabajo
ideal van a ver adversidades van a ver
miles de cosas malas pero piensan que
trabajar duro por algo que no te importa
se va a llamar estrés pero si trabajas
por algo duro por lo que tú amas en
verdad le vas a llamar pasión y es lo
que yo a muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]